packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on so sit
back and enjoy my delicious simple
suppers
one of my Essential mantras for becoming
a better cook is it's all about building
your confidence and the way to do that
is with practice
to have a repertoire of easy dishes you
want to cook and eat time and time again
and soon you'll be on your way to
becoming a kitchen demon
my first dish keeps it simple but
delivers big time on Flavor so it's sure
to become a regular quick supper fix
spicy tuna fish cakes I love this recipe
why because it turns this humble
ingredient a can of tuna into something
delicious
just
open up
and drain the tuna into a sieve
just slightly flake that
don't press it too hard otherwise you'll
dry out the tuna
now these are water chestnuts just
slicer nice and thin
you can buy them anywhere any
Supermarket chestnuts and fresh ginger
get rid of that rough skin on the
outside
by grating the ginger you get to get all
that really nice
sort of juice
in
take your spring onions and just slice
on an angle I like the texture of the
water chestnut
with a spring onion
a touch of fresh coriander
lovely
next remove the seeds from a chili to
reduce its heat without losing any
flavor
and finely chop
chilies in kaffir lime leaves roll them
up nice and tight run your knife down
the center
once and just chop
and that makes the fish cake nice and
fragrant
such as salt
a touch of pepper
fish sauce
just lightly seasoned
tuna to bind all those one of the
ingredients two whole eggs
and give that a nice little whisk
and then
at your ex keep your hands in there
and start mixing
get the mixture
roll it from hand to hand
with the Palm Pat them down nicely
to cook add a little ground oil to a hot
pan at the face of a clock I'm going to
go from 12 all the way around
first one in
these fish cakes only take a few minutes
to cook so keeping track of the order
they go in the pan means you know which
one to turn first
okay
and a nice gentle little Shake make sure
that nothing's sticking to the bottom
spatula
two fingers on top turn them over
beautiful that crackling noise is
something you always want because the
tune is already cooked so we just
lightly frying as we get a nice crisp
outside and gently take them out
smell incredible
sit there I'm gonna make a really nice
delicious simple dipping sauce start off
a little Pinch of Sugar fish sauce two
tablespoons that gives it the saltiness
one tablespoon of rice wine vinegar
and fresh lime juice
squeeze all that lime in there your
fresh coriander lots of coriander and
then
give that
a little mix
and then you have the most amazing spicy
tuna fish cakes who would have thought
something as delicious as that can come
out of a can
a simple supper in minutes that's so
mouth-wateringly easy and delicious
you're guaranteed to cook it again and
again
when it comes to Simple Cooking there
are two basic bits of Kit I'm never
without that will save you time and
effort in the kitchen a grater and a
peeler the swivel peeler a stainless
steel one
that's incredible it's almost like a
lifesaver in the kitchen because they
are so quick so light swivel blade so
we've got so much more flexibility you
can actually go around the vegetable and
we call it speed peeler in a
professional kitchen because it does
literally
absolutely rapidly peels your vegetables
you have minimal waste
and are great for everything from
peeling veg to finely slicing cheese and
making shards of chocolate a good
comfortable grip and a sharp stainless
steel blade ensures you'll always work
fast
the Box grater is another great
versatile kitchen tool and with his
Planes will cause grating fine grating
and super fine as well as blades for
slicing it's perfect for everything from
purine Ginger and zesting lemons to
shredding onions super small so they can
caramelize in a Flash and be sure to get
a solid handle to hold it firm
it's got such volume inside it doesn't
Crush everything up so I always prefer
the grate onto a tray or into a bowl so
you don't have to move it again grating
onto the board you've always got to lift
it up and place it in so Place The
Grater into a bowl and Grate two simple
but essential Speedy bits of Kit
guaranteed to make your life in the
kitchen easier
bread is a brilliant base for delicious
super fast lunches and suppers here are
three of my deliciously simple recipes
that transform a humble bit of bread
into a gastronomic treat
first up flatbreads with fennel and feta
add olive oil to a flatbread
then place in a hot frying pan and toast
until crisp and golden on both sides
these deliciously versatile breads are
made without yeast and are available in
good supermarkets and local Middle
Eastern shops
next thinly slice fresh fennel and
Scatter Over The Toasted flatbread
then toast aromatic fennel seeds in a
hot dry pan and sprinkle on top
[Music]
crumble over wonderfully Tangy feta
cheese
finish with a drizzle of sweet and
sticky pomegranate molasses
bread transformed before your eyes
flatbreads with fennel and feta simple
delicious and ready to eat in minutes
[Music]
my next recipe that turns a hunk of
bread into a stunning dish is bruschetta
with garlic Tomatoes Capers and pecorino
[Music]
start by slicing a baguette diagonally
to get a large surface area so it holds
more of the delicious topping
drizzle the bread with extra virgin
olive oil
then place it all side down onto a
scorching hot griddle
when the bread is beautifully charred
remove and rub with a peeled clove of
garlic paint attention to the edges
next half sweet cherry tomatoes and rub
the juices into the toasted garlic bread
then simply crush on top
[Music]
next slice and Scatter over Tangy Caper
berries and use a veg peeler to add
shavings of salty pecorino cheese
finally drizzle with extra virgin olive
oil and add a Twist of black pepper and
fresh flavors in a flash of a griddle
pan
toast has never tasted so good
[Music]
perfect for a simple light supper or an
easy lunch my next dish is a cannellini
Bean crostini with anchovy and olive oil
[Music]
popping heat olive oil in a frying pan
add tin cannellini beans along with the
juices
it's heated gently mash the beans with a
fork
sliced black olives
roughly chopped parsley
a splash of Sherry vinegar season
and leave on a gentle Heat
next half a festive batter
and splash with extra virgin olive oil
heat a griddle pan until smoking and
toast the bread oil side down pressing
it into the pan to char evenly to serve
top the toasty chapata with a cannellini
Bean mixture
and finish we chopped anchovies
packed with bold flavors so easy you can
always make it blindfolded ready in
under 10 minutes but eaten in seconds
three different breads three fantastic
recipes proof that even when you're
pressed for time you can still eat like
a king
incredible
cooking at home for special occasions
falls into two camps sit down Affairs
where the food's a bit more formal
and relaxed parties where dishes are
laid out and people can choose what they
want to eat and when
if you're cooking for a party always
make dishes that are colorful vibrant
and exciting to eat
so you'll grab your guest attention and
really wow their taste buds my first
dish has plenty of attitude enough for
any special occasion
a flavor-packed green papaya salad this
is a great salad to serve at a party
it's delicious and robust enough to last
the whole evening without wilting
first off these are a little dried
shrimp you can buy them anywhere
they smell almost sort of the seabed
into the pest and water for this salad
inspired by my travels across Thailand
I'm starting by making a wonderfully
spicy paste a little salt in there in
break them up this place is like a
staple ingredient in Thailand that's
what we're looking for almost
it's like a powder right next just one
clove of garlic
slice up the garlic
and get that into the pest and water
bird's eye chili incredibly hot powerful
but wow it does give an amazing kick to
the pace
[Music]
in
to the mix
now a couple tablespoons of brown caster
sugar
that softens the blow with a chili and
then just to get that nice sour taste a
little bit of hot water into this
Tamarind paste it's really tart but
sweet paste one tablespoon in
fish sauce now it's got that almost sort
of pickly smell slightly salty but the
flavor is intense two tablespoons and
bring that together
and give it a really good mix
some lime juice
and half Another Touch of sort of
tartness
the paste is nice and thick and fragrant
but it's got the heat the sourness the
tartness
incredible
Green Papaya stand it up
to give it a little peel you can find
Green Papaya in local Asian shops and
bigger supermarkets and as it doesn't
Wilt like more delicate Veg it's perfect
for robust salads like this a great hit
look that's what I want these thin
slivers next a nice rich
sweet banana shalom
[Music]
nice some carrot
Cara gives it another texture
[Music]
now nipple that and mix it
finish that off with Thai Basil and
fresh coriander
Thai Basil is a much more fragrant basil
it's stronger and it's slightly thicker
as well
like the pine and Tamarind paste you can
get Thai Basil in good supermarkets and
independent Asian stores but normal
basil works well too
next prepare the crunchy topping pan on
and toast some peanuts
chop the nuts but it gives a really nice
crunch
there we go
rolling around the pan
gas off
I just took them out
of the exciting Palm we're going to
dress the salad
nice spoon of dressing in to the papaya
mix that in
and finally our nice General sprinkling
roasted nuts
and that is one delicious very fragrant
very robust
green papaya salad
so easy to make and guaranteed not to go
limp a perfect party salad and with such
incredible colors textures and bold
exciting flavors it's sure to grab your
guests attention when you're putting
together a feast for the family or
friends it's great to have some
bulletproof salads in your cooking
repertoire here are three more of my
favorites to set you up
foreign
first my delicious chopped salad
[Music]
sliced cherry tomatoes in half
and add to the Bowl
along with chopped red pepper
and finely diced shallots
next slice salami into strips
and add follow with nutty chickpeas
and smooth Eden cheese cut into
matchsticks building up different tastes
textures and flavors as you go next add
chicory for a deliciously bitter bite
then chop crisp romaine lettuce
and add for the dressing finely chopped
garlic
add Cherry vinegar a shake or spicy
Worcestershire sauce cast the sugar
and olive oil
then simply whisk
pour the dressing over the salad and mix
so that everything is Thoroughly coated
finally sprinkle with dried oregano for
an aromatic finish hey salad so easy if
you can chop you can make it with such
delicious results it has to be tasted to
be believed
[Music]
my next simple salad that's perfect for
a party is green bean salad with mustard
dressing
[Music]
for the dressing wrap a whole bowl of
garlic in foil and roast it in a hot
oven
next add top and tail green beans to
salted boiling water
and cook for just a couple of minutes
this is called blanching and keeps the
beans deliciously crunchy
strain the beans
and refreshing cold water this stops the
cooking process so to stay crisp and
green
[Music]
next remove your garlic from the oven
off the head
squeeze out all the Glorious garlic
which has gone creamy mellow and divine
in the oven
[Music]
then simply add sharp white wine vinegar
a dollop of Dijon mustard
sweet runny honey
season
and pour in a good lug of olive oil then
whisk
at the crunchy blanched green beans
topped with toasted almonds for a lovely
nutty note and crunchy texture
mix well
and serve
Heavenly mustard vinaigrette with a hit
of mellow roast garlic stunning green
beans dressed to perfection
[Music]
my next salad that's great for any big
bash is roasted red pepper lentil and
Herb salad
[Music]
free lentils to vegetable stock
along with a bay leaf and boil for 15
minutes
free lentils are perfect for sellers
they have a great meaty flavor and a
delicious bite for texture
next chop sweet red peppers
and place on a baking tray
along with diced courgette
drizzle over olive oil
season
and roast in a hot oven
[Music]
to assemble the salad place the drain
lentils in a large bowl
then add olive oil
[Music]
and chop some blushed tomatoes
take the roasted red peppers and
courgettes from the oven and add
along with chopped avocado as its
delicious creamy flesh give the salad a
lovely contrast
season then for a big Herby hit chop a
handful of chives and basil
and add
squeeze over lemon juice and mix
earthy aromatic and packed full of
goodness absolutely stunning serve with
roasted meats and fish or perfect eaten
just by itself
good
three incredible salads all bursting
with flavor color and health so quick
and easy to prep and utterly delicious
you'll be making them every day not just
on a special occasion nice
[Music]
I'm back to my ultimate cookery course
these are my perfect TV dinners
next up my guide to getting the best
ingredients for your money my shopping
Mantra is very simple first rely on your
senses make sure whatever you're buying
it looks smells and really feels good
and if you get the chance to taste it
before you buy it then do it second is
to recognize that knowledge is
absolutely crucial the more you know
about where your ingredients are from
and how they produce the better so don't
be scared ask lots of questions and
learn
and when you want a simple supper herbs
are perfect to use in your cooking they
add vibrancy and amazing depth of flavor
and once you get the hang of them they
are so quick and simple to use and one
woman who really knows the chef's best
friends is expert herb grower Lorraine
Melton I love herbs I love the way you
can cook with them I love the smell of
them she's been growing an incredible
array of herbs in the wet Cambridgeshire
Countryside for over 20 years and can
smell a Bay from a basil at 50 pesos we
grow about 150 varieties of herbs it's
always interesting interested to grow
new varieties see what they taste
taste like broadly speaking you get
harder herbs and softer herbs softer
herbs are things like Parsi basil rocket
coriander
we grow um two main types of pasta so
we've got flat leaf parsley and curly
parsley flavor wise I think they're very
similar although a lot of people would
say that the flat leaf parsley has got a
stronger more aromatic flavor this is
your common basil sweet Genovese this is
a purple variety called Reuben we're
doing Greek Basil Thai Basil holy basil
when you're looking for a basil you want
a bright fresh basil nice leaves no
blemishes and nice strong stems it's got
a lot of oils in it and it's very strong
smelling it just tastes the summer basil
Lorraine certainly knows her stuff and
she's right soft herbs are delicate so
for maximum flavor always use them at
the end of cooking or simply add as they
are to cold dishes here are my top five
soft herbs that I could never live
without
[Music]
basil as Lorraine says it comes in many
types all with an amazing sweet punch
and flavor great blitzed in pestos
sprinkled whole over mozzarella and
showing its versatility it even makes a
wonderful ice cream
parsley beautifully earthy and intensely
fresh use both the leaves and the stem
for great depth of flavor in savior
dressing soups and salads
coriander for an amazing hint of citrus
often used in Thai Dishes coriander is
perfect in curries and chutneys but it
bruises easily so treat it with care
tarragon a staple of French cooking this
has long soft green leaves and a
distinct antacid flavor great with
chicken or in Rich creamy sauces
finally Cherville both mild and sweet a
perfect pairing with fish an incredible
mix simply with melted butter for a
quick sauce those are my favorite soft
herbs what about the hard ones the
harder ones tends to be a more Woody
plant things like thyme Rosemary they've
got your common time which is your
ordinary General bog standard cooking
time and then you've got things like
lemon thyme we do an orange thyme which
is actually one of my favorites it
smells like thyme but it's got a deep
sort of musky scent as well which is
going to give you a slightly different
flavor in your dish
hard herbs like thyme can take more
intense cooking than soft herbs so
they're great in stews roast or pan
frying choose the right one and you can
add wonderful depth of flavor to your
dishes here are my top five I use day in
and day out
Rosemary amazingly robust with great
Bittersweet green leaves it's a classic
pad with lamb delicious sprinkled over
specialty breads like Focaccia or great
as toppings for Fruity sorbets
Lorraine's favorite thyme a heavy
aromatic pungent herb which adds
delicious flavor to a Sunday roast it's
amazing with wild mushrooms and is
perfect in marinades
oregano warm and full of delicious
aromatic oils a staple of great Italian
dishes and perfect sprinkled on pizzas
or in pasta sauces
[Music]
Sage a strong tasting herb with a
deliciously bitter flavor incredible in
stuffings and with Rich Meats like pork
or duck
finally Bay Bittersweet and spicy it's
delicious simmered in soups stocks and
risottos and just as good dried or fresh
growing herbs is a lot easier than
people think it is on winter boxes in
balconies and it's great you can just
open your window put your hand out and
snip some off
when you're out looking for hers make
sure they're not nice and healthy no
blemishes stems look strong they should
just spring back it's a nice springy
sort of herbs smell obviously is quite
important not all things smell but
obviously if you think it's one that's
going to smell like lemon thyme it
should have a nice fresh lemon scent and
obviously the final one is taste you can
tip a bit off
and taste your herbs and you can see
what they taste like them
whether bought from a supermarket or
picked from your window box herbs are a
great way to add fresh flavors to your
dishes perfect for delicious simple
suppers
even if you've got a super busy
lifestyle it doesn't mean missing out on
delicious desserts they just have to be
simple to make
when it comes to cooking at home
puddings should always be a pleasure and
never a chore and homemade puds are 100
guaranteed to impress
my next recipe has only two main
ingredients but Simplicity doesn't mean
food can't taste out of this world
incredible griddle pineapple with spiced
caramel if you're making a dessert for
one or two it's gonna be quick and easy
there's Sumptuous delicious griddle
pineapple fits the bill perfectly
thank you
pineapple way of testing is nice and
ripe
top of the leaves come out perfect ready
to go
always cut a pineapple with a straight
edge knife slice off the bottom
turn it back over
and slice the top part
now keep that
for later
look at the core the center of the
pineapple and slice down
directly in half
slice that in half
take each quarter and slice them
smells incredible
lay down flat just slice
that core off
so you've got this perfect sort of boat
on pineapple slice underneath but stop
as you get right at the end slicing
around the skin will make the pineapple
easier to eat but leaving it attached
gives you more control as it Cooks
next Heat a griddle pan as hot as you
can start off
in the corner and push it down
to really Mark the pineapple
two minutes on each side and then just
turn them
really nice color now that beautiful
I'm going to sprinkle them
with a little touch of sugar that's
going to glaze them
now
slice the top
take out these beautiful glazed
slices of pineapple
next up the spice caramel now start off
with your pan
nice and hot
sprinkle
four tablespoons of sugar in there just
flatten it
then add the seeds from a fresh vanilla
pot in
a small dusting of Chinese pie spice
never stir caramel let it sort of bubble
and transform
here she goes
now I've got the color I've wanted
that's the perfect color off with the
gas
in with a butter then
[Music]
a couple tablespoons of cream lovely and
then give that a little whisk add the
rest of your cream
[Music]
nice
and just drip
that spicy caramel
over your pineapple
hmm
wow
simple elegant and seriously impressive
griddle pineapple with spiced caramel a
delicious treat all to yourself so that
tastes even better share
next my trick is the trade and kitchen
tips first up the proper way to chop
fresh herbs to get maximum flavor
chopping herbs the secret is to chop
them not bruise them now basil
it's a soft herb so treat it with some
respect when people go mad chopping
herbs all the goodness comes out on the
board I want the goodness left inside
the basil place them all inside one
another with the largest
Leaf at the bottom and it's almost like
rolling a cigar large one at the bottom
small ones in the center
and then look place them down together
and just roll them nice and gently don't
bruise them
step one rolled ready to slice sharp
knife imperative fingers tucked in
the bottom part of your knuckle is the
guide between you and the herbs that
there
stops you from cutting your finger
really important to get comfortable with
a knife and just practice rolling the
knife across the board and relaxing that
wrist it's all in the wrist action so
herbs up
fingernails tucked
underneath and just up and down up and
down
and there you have a chopped basil
that's not bruised
and smelling very fragrant
right coriander so you get the bunch of
coriander hold it down
and just lightly shave the leaves off
the Stalls
Bunch them up together and then just
again let the knife do the work tuck the
fingernails in and just chop once and
once only don't hack it just chop it you
can always identify when you bruise the
herb when you've removed the herbs off
the board and there's a big green patch
full of flavor and none of the goodness
is left on The Chopping board
a great tip for using leftover herbs
simply chop finely mix into butter roll
up in clinical and freeze
then when you want a herbie hit cut into
slices and melt over steaks chicken or
veg
asparagus is great for a simple supper
to prepare always remove the Lower Woody
stem by gently bending and the asparagus
will snap at the perfect point
then boil Steam and serve with a little
of my herb butter
for a cracking soft boiled egg simply
place your egg in boiling water add a
spash of vinegar and cook for exactly
eight minutes
then plunge into ice water the vinegar
helps the shell peel off easily and the
Ice Water stops the egg from cooking
giving you the perfect runny yolk
for plus free salad dressings simply add
the ingredients into a Jam Jar screw the
lid on tightly and Shake to combine in
seconds there's no need to wash up a
whisk and the jar is ready made to store
any leftovers
[Applause]
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course coming up I'll be using fabulous
fruits to create a show-stopping dessert
every time I get to put one of these
together it's like a sort of little
jewelry box but first the key to dishes
that really impress is amazingly fresh
ingredients and it's essential to get
the best for your money when you're out
shopping so make sure whatever you're
buying it looks smells and feels really
good and if you get the chance and taste
it before you buy it
[Music]
a great tasting salad starts with
fantastic salad leaves and when it comes
to all things green there's little Dr
Steve Rothwell doesn't know
I think I am obsessed with salad I'm
obsessed primarily with Watercress that
that's in my heart because you know I've
got a PhD in watercress
a doctorate and salad we should all take
a leaf out his book then he's not only
been studying sadly for over 30 years
he's been growing them so he really
knows he's rocket from his Romaine
[Music]
there are literally thousands of
varieties of salad things like the
Tavian lettuce red vein spinach wild
Rockette Sorrel we grow virtually
everything outdoors and and we follow
the seasons so we're not forcing the
leaves we don't give them too much
fertilizer or irrigation we try to grow
them a little bit slower and that's the
way to get the best flavor and the best
quality of leaf we'll Harvest a crop cut
it in the morning and it's then on the
road going out to customers to be on the
Shelf the next day this is a great Leaf
baby leaf spinach and we call it baby
Leaf yeah quite literally because we cut
it when it's still in a baby stage
these are baby pea shoots we'll put
something like three or four hundred pea
seeds into the seed bed and then in as
little as 12-14 days they've grown to a
sort of a crop like this they've got the
flavor of fresh peas a bit of sweetness
and they've got a really nice soft
velvety Leaf texture
this is baby Watercress which is my
favorite salad crop of them all
Watercress is special because by
definition it's grown in pure flowing
water fresh water grass has got that
fantastic pungent peppery flavor
in Victorian London it was known as Poor
Man's bread whereby a lot of workers
would start the day with a Watercress
sandwich and if they couldn't afford
bread they just ate the Watercress
straight it is amazing full of flavor
I can't eat enough salad obsessed
Steve's spot on there's hundreds of
salad leaves available with different
textures tastes and colors here are five
my favorite everyday salad leaves and
don't forget some of them are delicious
cooked too
little gem sweet and crisp and an
amazingly dense heart these mini cos
lettuces are great simply braised in the
oven or use the leaves as Scoops for a
delicious chili beef filling
mustard leaves pungent spicy and full of
vitamin C these are a staple in Asian
dishes and are fantastic stir-fried or
steamed
Lamb's Leaf full of Tangy flavor and
with Incredible springy stems great for
hearty Robo salads or simply paired with
fish for a healthier simple supper
rocket these distinctive peppery leaves
are actually classed as a herb and are
perfect in soups or with fruits and are
full of iron
[Music]
finally chicory or ondive these tightly
packed red or white leaves have a
deliciously bitter taste and are great
wrapped in ham or alongside sharp blue
cheeses I think when you're shopping for
salads you can just shop with your eyes
if it looks fresh and healthy tasty it
is you want to look for bright colors I
like to see leaves with a bit of
moisture on them
sounds like to be kept cold and moist
basically So when you buy a pack of
salad put it in the fridge and if you
don't use it all in one go roll up the
bag to exclude Surplus air put it back
in the fridge keep it cold there's so
much choice of writing out there I
really do think people should be more
adventurous in their choice of salads
here both what they choose to try and
eat and and what they do with them so
get yourself some ingredients use them
boldly and your salad leaves can really
take Center Stage
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips scallops are a fantastic ingredient
when you want a special salad that
really impresses here's how to prepare
them do not be intimidated trying to get
the scallop out I'm going to show you
how easy it is to take them out and how
much more exciting it is to get them
fresh in the Shell so just basically
dessert spoon and a blunt knife
put the knife in
to the bottom and you just twist
open
Tilt The Knife up so it doesn't cut into
the scalloped meat run the knife from
the top
to the base
off with the lid no Flesh on there
and then from there that's called the
scallop skirt all you do is just peel
that forward and get the spoon to run
down the back of the shell and the idea
is to remove that little bit of muscle
that holds the scallop onto the bottom
shelf bang it pops out that's the top
the small side of the bottom
there's the muscle there and your thumb
just slides neatly in there and run your
fingers around and you just pop out
scallop
and look
bang beautiful this bit here is called a
skirt no use doesn't taste anything now
that's the coral you can slice that off
dry it in the oven and use it as a
powder for your risottos or even
seasoning fish with but that's the money
these just need to be rinsed under cold
water dried and ready for the pan
tomatoes are another salad staple here's
how to skin them for extra refinement
score each one with a cross at the
bottom blanching boiling water for a
minute then shot them in cold water and
the Skins will easily peel away
pomegranates are a fabulous fruit for
adding glamor to salads or desserts the
trick to getting the seeds out slice in
half lengthways make slits around the
edge turn upside down over a bowl and
using a large spoon whack as hard as you
can to release the seeds
to take fabulous fruit puts the next
level my tip is to add sophisticated
quinellas of ice cream or lemon
mascarpone
simply dip two metal spoons in hot water
scoop
shape and add
[Music]
and after baking never throw out your
leftover pastry it's easy transformed
into grapefruit or savory party nibbles
roll out
great parmesan or sprinkle over your
favorite fruit
roll
and then just slice and bake
foreign
[Music]
Chef knows at the end of a meal you want
to leave your guests on a high with a
spectacular dessert
[Music]
so when you're cooking for a special
occasion and want to make an impact it's
great to have a fabulous fruit dessert
up your sleeve
[Music]
my last recipe looks Sensational and
tastes just as good
raspberry milfoy
desserts should always have that wow
factor and this dish is incredibly
simple to prepare but it tastes and
looks absolutely stunning
[Music]
first off puff pastry you can buy
fabulous for pastry now a non-stick
baking tray and just lay the puff pastry
on the tray I want to get the top of the
puff pastry caramelized I'm going to
dust it in icing sugar
number three means a thousand layers
just lightly dust the top of the puff
pastry with icing sugar
we're going to start off in a hot oven
at 220.
for the first six or seven minutes and
then 10 minutes at 190 into the oven
foreign
fresh vanilla
cream in it
and start whisking
I want the cream whisked nice and thick
but look to all that nice fresh vanilla
seeds in there next
a nice scraping of orange zest
orange liqueur
don't whisk that in
fold it in
and that stops the cream from separating
lovely
now take that out of the bowl
and put it into a Piping Bag unwrap over
your hands
in a way that you're creating this
little pocket
snip off the end
nozzle
in
load up
your bag
just
twist slowly
There's No Air
the bag
it's nice and full
and firm nice chill your gorgeous
vanilla and orange cream in the fridge
until you're ready to pipe it
wow
that
is beautiful there's the layers there
that's the the Milford gently lift it up
onto the board
I'll slide into three
serrated edge knife
oh
beautiful start deciding on how you're
going to layer it
that bit there that's nice and firm for
my base that's nice and decorative for
the top and that bit there for the
middle
take out your cream
and put a little touch of cream there
and that just sticks that down
it stops it from sliding
pipe very carefully
a nice thin layer of cream around the
outside and come back into the middle
beautiful
now the rest was
sit them
two by two
now this layer
I'll turn it upside down and put the
caramelized part of the pastry on top of
the raspberries
every time I get to put one of these
together it's like a sort of little
jewelry box again cream
squeeze
on the back of the bag
so you've got control
they're asked with
two by two
I just want to put another layer of
cream on top those raspberries because I
want some height with my final layer
oh I just want to dive in there
put the lid on it
mmm
push that down
there you have a beautiful stunning
simple Milford a dessert to die for
and like all the dishes in my ultimate
cookery course I guarantee it will taste
as Sensational as it looks
[Music]
I've now shown you 100 recipes to stake
your life on smells
amazing simple and accessible dishes
look at that to give you confidence in
the kitchen hold the drum and slice
straight through and help cook yourself
into a better Chef really important to
season the mints before you cook it I've
shared essential tips and Insider
knowledge they don't actually smell much
but the flavor they give off is
extraordinary on everything from
shopping for great ingredients don't be
fine get your nose right into it to my
kitchen equipment Essentials The Secret
of brazing is having a really nice thick
durable pan and my ultimate cooking
lessons key mantras to make you Fearless
in the kitchen stripping away all the
complexity so you can whip up tasty and
delicious dishes with ease just finish
it with a little tablespoon of that
sauce and most importantly learn to
enjoy cooking at home incredible many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details
what are you waiting for go on get
cooking